all right and we are
live the last word with lord cognito and
ibontis
fresh on that friday evening campfire
kind of a
special guest going on yeah but before
we get that he
what's going on with you man how are you
man oh been busy
um man this week has been just kind of
crazy with just everything going on on
my side of the world like i injured one
foot
kind of let me get a little better
managed to rip off part of a toenail on
the other side so just good things on my
feet
so i'm like yeah vicious this is
kickboxing yeah
exactly yeah joys of being bare feet all
the time i guess but you get used to it
so
what are you gonna do but before we get
too far into anything that i got going
on
we got an awesome guest so let's bring
him in welcome
to the last word episode number 155. it
has been a glorious week for the little
lights with gcx raising
4.4 million for st jude's during this
year's charity stream marathon
absolutely amazing you guys can still
donate if you want to get out there and
do it
as for destiny the tower is not fine
and grand master nightfalls are showing
guardians they are no joke
this week we are joined by a grand
master guardian himself who has been in
the game
a long time now a veteran gamer like
your two hosts one who has spent
countless hours cooking heads
content creation started with another
franchise kill zone which then exploded
when destiny came onto the scene
since then he has been guiding new and
old guardians alike to victory through
this franchise
so joining us tonight is someone who
enjoys shredding a few notes here and
there on his guitars
putting some work in on the heavy bag
with his muay thai training
has a soft spot for jack russell
terriers and is always a helpful member
of the community with his youtube guides
and was even a long time co-host of the
guardian radio podcast
a true guardian to the end of the
franchise with his own custom
controller in hand to the end welcome mr
mesa shawn how you doing sir guys thank
you so much for having me on
those are uh some kind words you
definitely did your homework on
me man what's going on well first off
thank you guys so much for having me on
i'm excited to talk with you guys
tonight and talk some destiny talk and
anything else that you guys want to talk
about uh fellow
north easterner over here cognito
new york let's go yep met you a long
time ago
at the for what we were talking
beforehand destiny khan
i've known you for a long time my friend
so yeah just thanks for having me on
guys dude
absolutely it's like we've been working
through different guests and stuff and
we finally made timing work because
schedules get crazy and things are going
on i finally reached out and i was like
and you actually had some time i was
like
we made it happen so believe me thank
you for joining us yeah but no i was
like first time
obviously listened to guardian radio for
a while and you i knew got into hosting
and everything and by the time i
actually got to meet you guys
it was at the guardian radio booth and i
think cognino and i both probably
stopped by at different times but
i was the annoying guy who went to
guardian and that's like the only people
i knew
so i was like hunting around like i met
mark the night before
talked to him at like the wing place i
remember seeing you guys out there and
then i was just like i hung around that
booth way too long so
oh did i apologize too much it's funny
because
we got to get into it because last word
i would say
definitely the guardian radio tires and
macy's sean is a big
reason why we even exist because again
it was my first one also i was in that
booth way too long i'm like oh bases
here
i was like yo i still got the picture
bro i actually took the pick i'm like oh
i made it so while i'm there i guess
during that
that that whole time he was in that area
and i didn't know him and then
out we and him just started talking and
it was like yo this kid knows his
destiny
and then we eventually form last word as
a result
of that meeting so make sure you are 100
responsible for that yeah
you're the reason this is one of the
reasons this show exists well not me i
mean it's it's
it's more mark and k-dub i mean they
were the ones that started the show i
mean like they were the first
destiny podcast out there in 2013 you
know and um
then i came along i think first okay it
was like
mark and k-dub and then bell came on and
then biff was on for a bit and then i
came in
science guy what is his name i'm trying
to remember
that's right uh chris i wasn't on
when he was on yeah you actually
transitioned kind of when he went off to
go work on his like nasa moon probe and
stuff
yes yes anybody in chat knows who i'm
talking about you guys know is like he
literally
worked in christmas each i think hard
some hard wick no
i would i know i thought it's been too
long yeah i'd have to go
along yeah but yeah so i mean like
destiny podcast absolutely yeah yeah
and we did that for a number of years
and stuff and then you know it finally
just kind of
you know just kind of read its course
you know what everyone just having their
life things and stuff like that you know
and uh it was you know definitely some
great times and stuff you know i've met
a lot of great people
you know whether it was at guardian con
or through the podcast or
you know with bungie and uh yeah it was
awesome you know
yeah man before we even get into the the
content creation i wanted to
kind of talk to you just about i know we
kind of pre-show we're kind of like
talking games and
you know stuff like that and i just want
to get like early history
like what was some of the first games
that really got you
into gaming period for the very
beginning it's weird i mean like as a
kid it was your typical like
nintendo games and you know
uh getting quarters from my parents i'm
obviously no spring chicken here
but obviously you know getting quarters
from the parents to go to the arcade
yeah you know growing up in queens you
know what it's like obviously you know
um and then you know like nintendo but
then once
that all kind of went to the sideways
once i went to college and then
got out of college and then i was you
know working so much and either
first it was pharmaceutical sales for a
number of years and then medical device
sales for years
and then after that then um i uh
i would say that i'm i'm a recovering
call of duty
addict but i fully have relapse
uh on war zone because i'm too addicted
to worship
three years never mind
and i warzone to say i was like everyone
else
i i'm generalizing here i feel like most
people because i my
i made a video how destiny 2 can have
and how it would
would work uh to be a um okay could work
balanced and be fun and explode the game
to higher heights than we've ever seen
it
at battle royale and i've never had a
more vid a more disliked video in the
world but hey
dare to fail i don't care it's fine you
know i mean you gotta throw
i had to do it but at the same time i
was that
stereotypical i don't want to play
battle royale pub g
fortnite like those look silly right but
then my friends
my best friend from childhood was
playing war zone every single night you
know
and um i got so addicted to it there's
nothing the adrenaline rush you get
when you're in those finals like we had
when you know like the other night all
of us got a lot of kills and it was
final circles
and people are pushing and call out to
screaming and the
storms close in and your gas mask you
know like it's coming down and then i
got the final kill and of course
nvidia highlights doesn't capture the
final kill but shout out to your video
it's just it's really addicting and it's
also i mean i feel like it's great to
have
side games to play because if you play
one game because i feel like
that sometimes it's a common problem
with the destiny community sometimes if
you play
only one game it's easy to get burnt out
you know like myself include in this and
that so
having other games to play when there's
times when there's not a whole lot to do
or there's other things
honestly makes me appreciate it you know
because i was playing warzone all week
and then last night we were spent two
hours
trying to do the grand master shout out
to rob and uh blackwood trying to do uh
grand master and uh it was not happening
so i believe hung jury is next week and
it's inside terminus which
the final room doesn't have champions
where the final room for glassway
is um they have too many champions you
know
and i know there's a cheese for it and
like i think
one of us tried to do the cheese and
then i tried to get in the spot and it
was like
it's too for me i don't have the
attention i have the attention span of
an angry mosquito so for me to sit down
in an underneath spot and just look up
through what happened
that's so boring for me like let's just
do it legit and uh
you know but it just wasn't happening so
yeah and
i have two decent plug ones i'll wait
until inside terminus next week to get
uh
hope i believe it's hung jury right chad
should be you let us know right now
yeah because i think the order was hung
jury then plug one and then i was
waiting to see the sniper and then yeah
it's the uzume
so okay yep those will be coming but
yeah it's like so definitely been
through shooters
that seems like your main stuff that
you've been through obviously
um what will that end of vision and okay
horizons are adorable
i covered a lot of because horizons are
dawn to me
still has the best third-person
mechanics
i've ever played in a game and it was i
normally never play
single-player games because okay i feel
like i like social games where you're
with friends
you've got your headsets on horizon zero
dawn just it took you in
this just other beautiful world out
there good story
but you felt like you were still playing
i need a looter shooter or something
tonight right
with horizon zero dawn you felt like it
was kind of eluded shooter because
you're finding new uh weapons you're
upgrading your armor
you're constantly crafting things but
the mechanics of
i mean shout out you know to gorilla
games on how they created that you know
um and the division one and the division
two yeah yeah
especially the division one i mean i
lived in that dark zone
i mean like literally even because for
me
it was the most uh unique pvp
semi-pvp experience because you'd go
into the dark zone either with friends
or solo
and i used to go solo all the time and
either you got to run into a-holes
or i've run into some cool people you
know what i mean where
you know and you you just that fear of
never knowing what's going to happen
laughing yeah or purposely that guy
running across you
so that you clip him with your gun and
now you go rogue and all sudden everyone
turns around on you
to start killing you but i remember you
know like one night you know just some
shenanigans you know muguan this
scottish guy
loved him to death we used to play all
the time we chased this guy around
the parking garage near the sports
center
for like an hour four of us and could
not kill him you know
and i was on playstation so we finally
messaged him afterwards like dude
can you please tell us what you're
running and he's like what's your build
yeah it was a glass
you know build he couldn't do that much
damage so he didn't really kill any of
us but we just could not kill him and
stuff like wow
yeah and the division too i liked it but
i kind of i don't know what it was i
just kind of i tapped out
around when the first raid came out yeah
that happened to a lot of people i think
the ones who tried it
it was all about everything had to be a
dps pill and that's what everybody
seemed to have success on so a lot of
the people who seemed to build into
anything else when the raid came out
there wasn't about support it was just
trying to do enough damage to keep up
with the pace of their aid and
sadly when people are like well now i
gotta go back and grind this one or
there's
something else yeah it's division has
been a very interesting one for
like competition to destiny because it
has had some weight to throw at
the population yeah and division one did
better
kind of taper it off you know ransom
course and then two came and just didn't
hold
quite as quickly but it's always been
the one that i feel had the closest
attempt at
the biggest chunk of the destiny
population for a little while at least
yeah
the the one game that i was so
disappointed with because i had
so much hope for it because the gameplay
mechanics
was just oozer fun is anthem okay oh
yeah
absolutely the flying the shooting the
power the super powers
everything was amazing amazing but then
when it came out it just had so many
issues with regards to whether it was
loot
whether it was bugs whether it was the
way you walked around the social space
it didn't
it didn't feel like a social game and
you know i
i'm part of the ea game changes you know
i can't talk about
certain things but i was there along the
journey before
i saw netflix
a lot of suggestions i did make some
suggestions you know
um but none of those suggestions made it
into the game
uh so um that was a sad story because
and bioware is such a good company too
man you know like so for them to pull
the plug in it for e
i don't know if it was bioware the it
was ea that pulled the part right on
so i was sad about that one too you know
because i always feel like again
it's not about competition it's about
you know
well one yeah i mean like healthy
competition helps everyone improve you
know because like if
if destiny 2 has some healthy
competition it helps destiny you know
like step up their game when you know
cod has
you know like the new battlefield you
know the trailer came out and stuff
hopefully that's going to give cod a run
for its money you know they don't have a
battle royale you know
i i really want to see what halo
infinite is going to be like because
this may sound bizarre but i've really
never played that much halo at all i
i launched into bungie games with
destiny alpha
once i logged in as you can see the
guitar is in the background as a
musician as soon as i heard that music
they they just had no idea
that strike had to just like speak to
you oh
all i wanted was this uh cydonia ar3
cydonia something i think it was during
the alpha and beta
i would grind over and over for it um
but i feel like yeah like
when i first saw the trailer i was like
what is this because i was all a
multiplayer channel this tiny channel
covering kills on shadowfall which i
still love to this day but i don't think
there's going to be a kill zone any time
girl seems busy with other things yeah i
mean like once
horizon took off i think that's their
franchise probably you know
yeah um but i was a guru i was a huge
fan of kills on shadowfall and then
i saw the trailer for this game called
destiny with aliens and
the moon and uh it looked silly to me
and i was like you know
whatever and then i got the email that
you could play the alpha you know
because i applied for it and then i was
in there i logged in and i was like
i was like this is so unique because i
had never played a pve
game which is now the focus of my
streaming and channel is all pve
i mean right because i am well besides
the fact that i am god
awful at pvp i mean you don't that's why
i nicknamed myself bed ames mcgillicuddy
early on because it disarms the trolls
because when someone comes into my
stream or chat and says
he's got hard blame i'm like tell me
something i don't know
believe it or not that's what's up
because i know you're gonna say
something about anthony with some other
stuff and then i gotta go oh
no i mean anthem's just one of those
that i mean yeah it's
just the way that was handled i
literally just got done finishing mass
effect 1
just recently and that for a 14 year old
game you can tell us there's some dated
stuff in there but the
world they built and cognito knows all
about like
one two and three and which one you know
they have had their whole debate on
their podcasts and stuff
but i love one though so i still love it
too you see the world that they built
in mass effect 1 and that i've only
heard it basically takes off and
runs from there when you finish mass
effect 1 i'm like all right they did
something
really cool and when you played through
anthem i'm like you missed but it was
also like you read through jason
schreier's
stuff about anthem and you're like we
are lucky to have even been flying in
that game because there was a point they
were like no flying be like okay put
back in flying and you're like
that was even an option because it felt
so good because
like to jump i always i played the
interceptor because i probably made my
stream throw up because i'd always run
around and jump
but i love the way it felt and then on
the other side you have the
storm and just the way the animation of
the lightning literally like your whole
screen would come down
that was me the storm yeah like the i
love the look at the warlock
that's what exactly yeah i'm a warlock
gravitate tool
i'm in the minority tonight mine already
here we because i got a warlock movie
i'm good you had a bunch of titans for
the last oh i didn't have a run i didn't
find
a warlock with me let's go yeah no we're
both warlocks here so
yeah absolutely but yeah it's like
that's the type of stuff when you see
after playing mass effect 1 i'm like you
know the mako there's some repetitive
like there's stuff you can pick apart in
the game but the the
depth they put into that game i was like
oh man if you had that depth with the
how
mass effect felt sold like it would have
been fantastic but
they missed so hard and that was like
that was the one i'm with you it's like
division was cool like the military but
unfortunately after playing destiny the
realism of division i think is one of
the things that held it back because
you're always
you know shooting dudes in coats and
armor like you can't shoot giant alien
night high bosses and stuff they don't
exist so
anthem had that hope of a little sci-fi
and everything else and now it's like
every so often like somebody talks about
them like man i'm with you it's like
that
i i was hopeful so yeah that's it's sad
but yeah i'll join you guys you got to
say real quick about just real quick
okay you could appreciate this because
you're from the new york area
do you remember in the division one
you'd go into a safe house and you would
hear
yo this is rick velasly with pirate
radio podcast he's like
this would go out to all the five
boroughs except staten island you're not
a real
borough because that's how we are that's
like
brooklyn bronx manhattan staten
see that island one thing i heard i know
it wasn't one to one but there are some
points like
if you knew the east coast at all
sometimes you guys would walk around and
be like
that does actually kind of look familiar
it may not be perfect but they did
something
i used to live in murray hill on 34th
and first and i'm like
that looked like my old building back
there yeah
i think i think that's what it was too
for me mesa with division one because
as a new yorker you appreciate it yeah i
mean the base was the garden
it just it really spoke to you and i i
still i think don't get me wrong dc was
cool
in division two yeah yeah i like that
it's just never gonna beat that snowy
cold
new york division one and that actually
really made me connect with the game
and the fact that i think that survival
mode which i really liked
um it did i have to admit when division
one first dropped
my destiny friendliness they they
betrayed me they
they're like cog we're over here and i'm
like at first i went through that period
of trying to resist
because i was so loyal to destiny but i
was just like look it is fun
you know what i mean i had to i had to
admit now obviously as it went on and
then
you know some mistakes that destiny
probably came around i think once taken
king came back and all that stuff it was
like nothing out of it
but yeah division shout out to shout out
to the elemental in there a lot of
people in there division guys
you know and slo-mo if he's in there but
um yeah i have to admit
it was it was truly transformative for
his time i think
um destiny that's that that gun play
that hook but what i wanted to ask you
because i know you said you got an alpha
you immediately got hooked
you know all that stuff but we gotta say
something you know fellow warlock to
warlock here you know yeah
okay what was it about the class sir
what was it about it that
the thing you gravitate towards it i'll
use dj's quota say
it's because we we're robes okay no um
i actually played as a hunter for the
first three months until i discovered
the warlock right
and i think well one is for pvp
if i actually do play it i'm always
blank warlock right i just love it
um sunsinger for destiny 1 because i
just loved
always being mister clutching crota's
end or
whatever just you know listen warlocks
don't die we just multiply you know what
i mean like
you just sell fresh you know um and
storm trends
and everything um i don't know i think
also i i know people hate the jumping on
it but
i think i'm just so used to it you know
by now and almost i feel like no offense
titans it's a little passe
i feel like titans are a little bit 2018
okay everyone's a titan and everyone on
twitter the titan
okay i don't know it's good for me it
goes warlock then hunter and then
i still love the titan you know that's
one of the things like or the beauty of
destiny 2 is
all the classes have their flavor and
all the subclasses have their flavor you
know
but the warlock i would say um i would
it's just
really the abilities i mean to go around
and electrocute things
fun the ability to go and throw flaming
swords
fun to throw a huge nova bomb fun
you can apply the same thing to the
titan or to the hunter
with their abilities too you know and
the fact that they reintroduced
all those subclasses and i do like the
fact that
we're the only ones that have little ice
turrets for stasis
i got stopped for a second i gotta ask
you a tougher warlock i've never asked
this before
oh now which subclass
gun to yeah you could only have one
warlock so like one of
nine one of them now ten technically
well done
well he i could let him cheat and say
void solar
stasis you know what i say but you know
want an arc so
one if you could only go one which one
would it be
i've always been a solar person so i'm
gonna say even
as much as i love icarus dash uh in top
tree
there's nothing more fun than when
you're on bottom tree warlock
and you're just clearing out the room
because
every time you get a kill you see your
supervisor you go right back up
and you just you your trash mobs are
being destroyed
and set up on fire and you're using that
chorus with that sir are you using that
door of course that that
the bug helps with that sir my name is
because i'm a panic reloader and i know
people are going to say you should just
use transgressive steps
i always use affinion aspect it's hard
for me to take it off because
it looks cool and it just you throw on
an extra reloader onto it like hand
cannon reloader on it like it's
okay a fitting aspect with uh hand
cannon reloader on malfeasance
it feels like you have permanent outlaw
on the gun it reloads so quickly you
know
but i would say um yeah probably solar
bottom tree dawn blade if i don't have
to run support which is going to be
um well of radiation no no listen man
you
i think that's a strong sign of justice
yeah
yeah you got your jack of all trades you
got support well you know if you want i
know you're not a people if you want
superior pvp movement you got top tree
with your dashes and heat rising
and then you got your ultimate pve with
bottom tree dawn
and you're just clearing out those ads
and the suit i'm with you man that's a
good choice
i always want to ask that we gotta ask
more of that um yeah when we get
people on sub like like a subclass
figure class
like you know what speaks to your
personality like your personality
i will depending on what i'm doing like
if i'm doing guides it's literally what
fits
but especially for like subclass or burn
or anything on a lot of these lost
sectors lately
if i'm just going to go pick something
for fun though it's hammer titan
typically yeah
because literally as soon as i got my
like i was hunter and d1 until
hammer titan dropped and then i flopped
and then i've been literally titan
maning since
um because i always enjoyed it top tree
titan
yeah let's go pvp will be top
and then pve bottom especially now with
phoenix uh
phoenix cradle yep phoenix cradle the
new they last forever like
the sunspots yeah so like the sunspots
in pve now
oh man yeah that in phoenix cradle if
i'm just like wanting to goof around
yeah just hammers for days yeah so many
hammers so
yeah i've always been what about you i
know you said warlocks
i think mason nailed it man because it's
like i couldn't
go without well at all when you're doing
you know hardcore content
but the most fun out of the solo yeah
would probably be bottom tree
just you know just the offensive case
especially like sun bracer builds
and you just got it's like you're
getting away with stuff bro especially
um you know you do let's say you do top
tree
you hit with the the the you know the
the projectile melee huh
you know what i'm saying off yeah you
spark off the the sun
bracer thing bro it just gets crazy so
it's like i mean we got to put a
disclaimer that we're not arsonists but
we like to burn things
as solar warlocks and with some racers
you know like you said it there's
nothing like
throwing a solar grenade in the middle
of you know you stun a champion i'm
always going to hit him with a solo
grenade yeah and he's going to burn to
death if like
fight stun him and then hit him with
breaching clear and throw a solar
grenade on him
he's dead as disco you know absolutely
now i will say
i know it's pv pve and i might get some
crap for this but i have to say i've
been
crutching stasis a lot as a wall
and yeah like it's pve hard content
surprisingly
because i guess you know just to be able
to stop everybody
got your turrets i think shade binder is
really underrated i mean
literally i mean we talked about it for
a second before but like grandmasters
right now is watching one it's
two sentinel shield titans and a stasis
warlock and even asked across as a video
about stasis warlock
it's apparently a thing i'm crushing it
because what it is i the crowd control
and then also
warlock supers are kind of hit and miss
in my opinion like we usually it's
either all boss dps like a chaos reach
but not good
ad control you know what i'm saying or
it's like good ad control with storm
caller
but not really good boss dps unless you
wear specific exotic
but what i like about shea but it does
good damage against bosses like
if you freeze everybody like so you get
a good combination
and i like it man you know you got your
death field and all this stuff it
doesn't feel
great yeah your survivability builds
with the one what's the one that gives
you the shards that give you extra armor
and
stuff like that so yeah i think i think
that's a honorable second
place for me but yeah definitely solar
if if that was you know yeah that's
gotta go to what's nice
you always need a warlock for that well
it was luna yeah
so i have to ask you because there's not
a whole lot of people that have ever run
through my twitter feed
i know you got into kickboxing a little
decent while ago now since i've been
following you
but um what guys
kickboxing absolutely um just tell us
kind of like first off what got you into
that like how much you've done with it
like
where what explain i mean i literally
teach fitness kickboxing classes but
they're kickboxing classes so i was like
i want to hear your side first that's
why i was like
you've always like i've seen it pop up
on twitter i'm literally like i have a
heavy weight a water-based heavy bag in
the other room and i'm sitting there i
can do a roundhouse in my house so
like yeah tell me about your story i
wish i had that no my ex
um ex-girlfriend she was always into it
she then said try it i tried it and
instantly once i find something i like i
just kill it i just really get into it
and then
started watching tons of youtube videos
on it and then i said you know what let
me do a few lessons with a private
fighter coach guy
and then you know he got me up and
running and stuff like that and
um i just kind of took it from there
just really fell in love with it you
know because it
it's you know like the discipline you
know like that's involved with it
um i know that you know people think you
use it you know
for fighting no no because the first
thing you learn is you never want to use
it if god forbid
you got into a street fight you just
want to give him a roundhouse or
something and get out of there
as quickly as possible you know but for
me it's more or less like
the cardio it um it changes your body
type
you know because i have the body type
where if i lift free weights i can get
really stocky and big
muay thai makes you very very like fast
and precise you know because because
you'll see some of these thai fighters
at like um because i train at ufc gym
and you'll see some of these tie
fighters you know who are from thailand
and all the tight shorts on everything
and they look like they're like half the
size of me in weight but when they hit
the bag
it sounds like a shotgun going off
and you'll see some big beefcake with
his half you know like tank top hanging
out with his tattoos and everything
right
he's gonna roll with him you know
everything that little tie fighter
will just beat the living hell out of
that if it ever came
um but yeah so it's one of those things
like it's addictive but
the same thing with you know since the
um the human malware hit
last year i got into running now so
that's my new thing now
is you know because i don't feel like
just you know getting in my car
you know getting into the gym bag and
then you know just having to deal with
other people
because all the weight machines are
taken and stuff like that or there's
tons of people
at the bags i like to just put on a
podcast or something like that and then
you know
just get on you know and just put my
running sneakers on
and just go running and then i actually
did my first 5k
last last um uh let's see what was it
november
september i think like that so congrats
that's awesome it speaks volumes because
literally the first time i tried i
couldn't run maybe 15
like half a block you know what i mean
like i'd be like
but then slowly you know i would watch
youtube video everything's on youtube so
i just started watching where
you run a little you walk a little you
run a little walk a little and then you
know
wait for the soreness you know like to
go away and then you know from there
yeah which is fun that's good brother no
i appreciate that he asked you that
because um
you know for us you know that's big what
what our communities and just
gamers in general fitness and and
staying healthy because let's be honest
we're playing these games we're sitting
with
we're being stationary you know so for a
long time and gamers
you know a lot of them are not taking
care of health so it's cool to see
that as big as you are as popular as you
are that that is still something that's
important to you
you know what i'm saying i do remember
you were definitely bigger when when i
first met you back then so to see you
really
transform and just take this whole thing
seriously
is really cool well you know what i
learned is that in 2007 when destiny 2
launched that month
i was uploading four videos a day it was
the biggest my channel ever grew
and i was working i got two hours of
sleep a night that month
i got bronchitis twice i got two middle
ear infections i got styes in my eyes
so ever since then i vowed one i need to
have a social life
two i need to have i need to go to the
gym i need
my quote unquote shawn time and you need
to have balance you know what i mean
because
i you know i don't god what's he saying
i don't work to live i
no i don't live to work i work to live i
guess what i mean
i have to have a social life and do
things outside of actually
um you know so that's why i need these
other things like having a social life
you know like going out on the weekends
the gym because i feel like also you
know like it's a fact
you know um rogan says this all the time
you know
if you're feeling down or or depressed
or you know
he's in the mood go lift some weights
okay go running go kick up
you know a bag go lift you know some
kettlebells
you probably will feel really good
afterwards because
there's no kawinkedenki that after
especially if i do heavy lifting
and i pound that protein shake
afterwards whoa i feel like i'm on cloud
nine yeah
i mean i feel like it's really important
preach it appreciate it i'm glad you
said that
because um yeah it's a big thing in our
community depression is real in our
community we have a lot
going on i'm always trying to help
people behind the scenes and stuff like
that
and i always tell people because they're
like you know how you do you always miss
the part i'm like bro i go through some
stuff just like you guys do you know
so at the end of the day it's just like
go work
even if because people are like yeah but
i was only there you know for a little
bit it doesn't matter you were there oh
i can't tell you
dude you know people see someone that
maybe might be
you know like out of shape or maybe you
know like heavyset or something like
that at the gym
and they think well you know like i'm
embarrassed no no no i see someone like
that
and i give them props so i'm like
they're doing something about it you
know what i mean like they're getting it
you know what i mean and like i respect
them for that you know what i mean you
know i'm like go get that you know what
i mean
um and uh yeah you know it's like we all
go through
horrible i mean i've been through some
horrific things that i'll never talk
about you know like in my life
and yeah you know it does help with you
know
mental cognition you know uh
you know just everything because let's
face it looking at these computer
screens although i got an imac here a
macbook here
imac there this screen here i go bonkers
sometimes you know i think
that's like i gotta and the joke is
always go outside because the
the graphics are 4k hd out there
they're pretty crisp out there if your
eyes weren't they're retracing
the ray chase is outside yeah that's
hilarious no that's like one of those
things
because part of what we do is like
you'll have people who've never done
kickboxing before walk in
and whether they're trying to change
their body trying to try kickboxing
trying to do something to change
like one of the things i tell everybody
when they walk in that's why i want like
when you guys said i just want to
reiterate it's like
whether you see somebody at the gym
who's like they have a long way to go
i'm like
you made the hardest step in the world
you walk through the damn door
like that's the hardest part and then
the other part is like even if you go
and you're like hey i work at like you
know five six days
this workout sucked stop saying that
because you got even if a workout's
fifty percent guess what you worked out
that day
you still had to be better off so i was
like yeah i just wanted to reiterate
that because i was just one of those
because it happens every day it's like
i'll tell anybody when they walk in i'm
like
i don't care how fast you go i don't
care first off safety and form when
you're doing kickboxing oh it's
important but
um anytime you're doing any of that
stuff i'd rather you go slow work on
form
go 50 speed because guess what you were
doing yesterday nothing
most likely everyone who comes in is
doing nothing
i'll ask so many people when's the last
team worked out i'm like they don't have
a date for that it's usually like years
they're trying to change
so it's like it's all those like if you
made it through the door and you're
trying
sweet so from there well make sure you
do it right but from there
like that's just start that's so cool a
great thing too that people don't
realize
that they're like that's not exercise
walking walking oh like i'll take max
here who's licking my feet right now
okay
for a good 45 minute walk that's still i
consider that some sort of exercise you
know
yeah
one thing you know just to touch on you
know maybe it's a little too much
information but
i was a heavy cigarette smoker okay and
when i
quit smoking i lost 10 pounds and most
people think that
you usually gain weight no it's because
from doing because i would literally go
to the gym to do muay thai
and i'd be like huffing and puffing
after five rounds of it and this and
that
but all of a sudden after like three
weeks i was like hmm
i'm breathing a little better then after
five weeks i'm breathing really good
then i'm doing seven rounds and i'm
doing eight rounds i'm doing nine rounds
and after
two months i'm like i can do some that
that uh you know some muay thai and then
i'm gonna go lift some weights and
then i'm gonna go cook myself in a sauna
so that was even more fuel
for me to never smoke ever again because
my my body changed my lifestyle changed
i drank a gallon of water a day now you
know what i mean it's just um
it's you know changing our daily habits
that i think you know
take you out of your comfort zone to um
take you out of your comfort zone
you will be more comfortable actually
you know absolutely yep yeah
good talks bro good talks you got
anything else for him
no no no man i've got a lot of games
like games last little thing
yeah so now awesome background and yeah
definitely say hello to uh
max at your feet i was like yeah he's
right how do you look at my feet
but when it comes to the world of
destiny
i want to start with the the weekly
stories that we've been going on and i
wanted to check
because i haven't checked in with you as
much to see how much we're keeping up
with the story
but obviously like with expunge and
things like now what the tower looks
like
i wanted to see where you guys are at
with like season of the splicer story so
sean i want to start with you first
where are you i'm still kind of confused
with the whole thing you know i mean
like i feel like bungie's definitely
gearing up for something
a live event i think because i i think
they saw how successful
the past two live events you know like
starting you know with the almighty
crashing and things like that and now
all of a sudden the tower these blights
are all on the left side of the tower
they're not on the right side of the
tower where
osiris is osiris are you implying
that but boys is up to something
osiris is suspect right now
everyone's ragging on my girl lakshmi
because i'm a future war called
die hard i know i'm the only person
that's not dead or bad
and he's swooning over here i know you
wouldn't tell spot let's go
yeah war is the only war is the only
constant
guardian she out here making the town
great again be careful
she's i don't know as much as i love her
she's been up to some shady stuff right
now
and um it's interesting to see how it's
going to play out
you know this whole time you know i mean
um but honestly what i
kind of like about is i don't have a
clue where they're going with this yes
and
the surprise of logging in every tuesday
to see what's going to happen
and at the same time also part of me
wants to think that they're teeing up
things for
the witch queen um even though the witch
queen is so far off you know
dominoes yeah you know what i mean so i
think one big huge buildup
you know and i'm really hoping the
season will lead into the witch queen
kind of bummed that the pyramids we kind
of forgot about them because
i've always i've been obsessed with the
pyramids forever
and when they finally arrived all i want
to do is please
show me what they look like you know
what i mean i just wanna you know
rumor has it those big statues with the
bail
that that's them you know what i mean
but i don't you know there's been no
hardcore proof you know like
that it is an innocent app but um will
the pyramids be involved with sabathune
but more than likely
when you see the image of lightfall with
the big pyramid in it more than likely
we're not going to see them until
lightfall and that they could be the
mastermind behind
you know everything that's going on it
feels like it's a ways away sadly yes
yeah so right now i have no idea
no it's good man it's it's again it's
it's it's great times right now he like
you know it's like to me it's like that
that that netflix series like tune in
next week or you know like or whatever
it's just i want to know what's going on
it's just that we don't have the full
netflix series where we could just binge
right right so we gotta you know we got
a great network show right now
or the disney show for whatever you're
watching yes
so pretty much man it's been that and
you know this week
another good mission you have you know
you got your sponge you got all that
and then we you know we finished the uh
the
the talk we go back to the splice and
you start to see uh my boy
oh susris as i gotta call him now
good old old suspicion all type of weird
things
he's just you know he's making saint
feel real good about all the things
dude man he is just gaslighting the crap
out of him it is hilarious
you know you should be a leader and you
know they they look to you yeah
i was like and i'm like oh my god it's
just going to go
trying to be puppet master over here
someone's playing someone over
bad there it is bad and and right now
to be honest it is getting scary with
the ramifications
each week how deep just go cause mesa's
mesa's girl is loose right now laxmi
she's loose
she's out here she's like last week
akora silenced me we ain't having it
and and you know the vanguard like she
she's starting
her cool and she's getting the
people in place to overthrow
aikora and zavala and it looks like poor
old
you know saint is in the middle being
kind of manipulated with this situation
in osiris so
we got that going on you know as to
what mason's point as far as the
overarching end game i feel
is gonna be you know which queen and
then lead into obviously um
what's going on going on with the what
we call them the space doritos yeah
so we got that going on yeah so look
it's gonna be this is setting up to be
one of their greatest stories i
i am curious the payoff
does it end with someone catching
osiris mid-transformation you know
because the rumor is right savage has
either he's either
been taken over you know you've taken
over his body or
sadly or my boy might be gone you know
what i'm saying because we've never seen
segura die on screen so that was another
thing so it's gonna be interesting but i
like what's going on
it seems like grave consequences it was
very interesting to log into the tower
and see all that taking stuff
it's okay i'm curious where you at with
the stuff no i mean you've touched on a
couple pieces
first off the tower is not okay it's not
on the other side
because i checked it isn't the main hub
i guess they didn't want to put the
visual pieces everywhere else but
um yeah your little taken simulation is
now
well your vex simulation is now a
take-in simulation
so the corruption from the vex network
is now coming in we've learned that
quaria
like uh what is it quaria blade
transform the dreaming mind like full
title
um she's the one in charge of this one
so it seems like we're going to be
facing off with her at some point
because it's like
we have to and uh mythrax is basically
trying to track down the best place for
her
us to confront quaria so
we are headed in that direction so
there's some type of confrontation
i'm hoping there's either a cut scene
you know an animated storyboard
something like that to go along with
whatever fight we have
yeah because i mean you know we killed a
high of god on mars
that was not the best way for that one
to go down
i mean i assume that we're gonna go
through like another expunge mission to
do it
so i assume that's how that's gonna go
but how they handle everything or like
it can be another expunge mission
fight it maybe there's some cool
mechanics something because i will say
in the expunge mission
for you know you're basically running
gambit on the outside when you do
override over and over and over again
but i was like that's kind of repetitive
but you do expunge we've got like
you know bring the you know run the
balls back and you've got hold the
square to build up your timer and then
you're running through and that was
sticks this week
and then you had leviathan and then next
week we've got tartarus where you're
shooting the cubes and it was like
they did a nice way of using mechanics
that we've probably seen
but to make these little short missions
have just enough variety where they
really do feel different
and i have enjoyed the fact that like
and then the taken had a little variety
this week where like you can't get
through until you take out the blight so
it's like if you make so little
variations have been nice
but taken versus the others they're not
that much different but i really have
enjoyed
how expunge has been building the little
text up in the corner like giving you
the whole thing saying hey you're going
to die
it's like you don't know it's like i
think that's quaria but there's that
sabathune through quaria it's like we
don't all of those pieces have been
really cool and i think you guys have
said it as like
this is some of the best story that
we've seen in the game
probably ever yeah because keeping us
wondering i think
is the biggest factor because it usually
because if we think of the d1 model it's
like
here's your dlc here's your story and we
as
destiny 2 fans are going to burn through
that real quick
and we're done with it and this and that
but having an ongoing narrative
i think is brilliant storytelling
because it for me at least as a player
it makes me want to keep coming back
to find out what the heck is going to
happen this week you know and
there's got to be some sort of exotic
quest coming at some point i'm thinking
i was like i will say like i have given
the
chapter a week a really hard time
but they're finally doing just enough in
the chapter of the week
that i don't totally hate it this this
this season
i'm still to the point where i would
love to know what happens because it's
killing me
you're muted by the way but
i said are you covered around e no i'm
not totally there yet i'm not suddenly
there like
it's not like perfect but i'm if it is
at this
level right then it is a lot more
manageable because it's like
i still have my variety games when
playing like played mass effect and
other things but my tuesday if i like
if i'm to the point where i'm like i i
cannot literally wait home to log in and
see what happens
this week like they've they've done
something right this
like chosen was cool like you know we
got to see kyle we actually got to see a
you know kind of an antagonist out
weird alliance thing going on and then
you turn and see
this season with like just the interior
civil war like again the puppeteering
and all this stuff you're like
this is actually legit so i'm like i am
i am
kind of ready it's it like we're close
at this point and i was like it
can't you know you can't have a 20
season 20 episode season it's like
you know we're at the end we got to get
there it's like we've kind of gone on
long enough but
so the fact that i don't hate it this
season definitely says something because
i gave i've given it some crap before
yeah yeah i'm glad to see you coming
around a little bit e this is big
i know that's it's very big you
basically don't know but this is a big
statement this man just made this man
would have been
that just goes to say how the quality
this season because yes
i mean you have ido in the camp when she
says dude they came in and crashed
our like travel model what the hell like
just the little stuff when you go see
everything i'm like
they've added so like the narrative team
has been allowed to just jam the season
full right
and i don't know if we've seen one like
this and that's what i think is changing
it for me where it's like
there's a little bit more to chew on
here a couple different people you know
different podcast opinions and stuff
it's been nice yeah i just want to add
them before i give it to mesa um
you're on the money with that and it not
only is premium storytelling this is the
first i got to be brutally honest like
shout out to bite shout out to the law
masters first of all right because the
guys that did in the work and do that
i'mma be honest i'm team lazy and i'll
wait for the video to come out
usually right when when when piff breaks
it down
and milan breaks it down cause i'm the
same way yeah right i don't
read the law even now that it's in game
i'm yeah guilty of charge i i complain
that it's not in the game
like in the game i'll read it right
i have to admit this season and last
season especially this season
when i finish the the you know you do
the override
which i love because i still love that
they add the voice actors and
you know you it's like a little living
story and them you know talking and
satan's all like we should destroy them
now and you know i
really don't just want to go like saint
goes crazy he's like why are we waiting
i love it right so you got all that
dynamic then you know you do your sponge
which is really cool
and stuff like that mythrax talks to you
you you start getting that
you know say your hat shout out to max
and you're getting that story time going
on right
but then what's going on for me that i
really like
is after you do it the lore piece
unlocks
and then you read something like
savithoon being you know
imposing and being an impostor or
something i'm actually
going to read the lore now i never
do that now they just need the final
level where they hire
life and you can do your codex thing
that you talked about or you hit play
and then he can read you the book there
we go
that's your final
final level is bioware mass effect level
lore codex with a voice person like bife
reading it yep and then you go oh no now
yeah then you could like okay i want to
go grind out some you know
whatever new basic strikes and be like
hey let me listen to a lore book like
i would totally do that yes i was like
and honestly you would probably get a
little bit more invested into it but
yeah that's that's like
way out there but overall i mean i would
definitely like that's kind of things
like if they're to the point where i'm
like
i'm ready for tuesday i wish i could see
it all faster i get it
but the fact that you're in the
anticipation mode means they are
doing things right they are they have
learned
a whole bunch in these last couple of
seasons and how to
make a story compelling they'll get the
little animated storyboard right they'll
have the voiceover lines that change
when you do this they'll have
npcs standing next to each other that
you've never seen ever
talking to each other and i'm like this
this in my face
story right here like this is this is so
good so
no that's been that's been really really
fun um
small side note yes because i have two
of them on this chat if you are a
warlock
and you listen to this episode this
weekend go
to zur holy crap his ear oh yeah
nazarick's sin
god rolling i've literally never seen
something that good from zur i don't
know if ever
and i've covered him for way too long
i'm just like i i literally
cursed in the middle of my stride i was
like holy dude i was like well
that was into the video it's a 68 stat
roll nezux
23 recovery low resilience decent
mobility
decent uh like 12 intellect 13
discipline 6
like 20 23 recovery on it recovery sorry
that's what i mean yeah
yeah six and i'm always
[Music]
people are happy with sir because
everyone hates because
because what i do is i stream zur on
fridays and then i trim the stream down
you know
just to a little quick video and even i
was shocked when i saw that because
normally everyone just rags on him every
week you know
but occasionally i always say zero is
for new players okay to get
exotics or stat rolls for us who may
have
those things ready so today was one of
those days you know that he had a good
stat roll on nzrx and i've
i need to go look at my rate in flux
because he may have a better role than i
have on my rate in flux my radio flux
trying to think is like that's not a bad
role now mine has a 25 intellect
on my right now my mine is pretty good
actually oh yes
yeah he had some decent utilities but
then i went to that one i was like what
like yeah yeah for sure winding cove edz
go check his little cliff and go by i
literally said in my videos like if you
thought about making a warlock if you
haven't played your world go buy the
damn thing
use it later like it's it's that good
like i never say that about these things
go buy it so
random side note but i was like sir
hooked up the warlocks this week like i
have
never seen and then what i want to do is
yeah i got to get it now because i've
got i finally got it i got a semi decent
grid skipper
and it's void pulse and energy so i love
anytime i as a wallet
you know maybe anytime you get a good
like void
energy weapon to rock with nazareth and
just keep
building ability and yeah yeah so i'm
about to go get that i'm about to go get
it get a better version
yeah my question to you guys i want to
ask before as we're talking about the
story thing and about having
an exotic quest okay since okay
obviously we all want a new exotic right
but if bungie was to bring back a
destiny one exotic through an exotic
quest this season
which exotic would you guys want to come
back i'm trying to think what happened
chad also let us know
the question is what hasn't come back
yeah i was like i've literally got to
look up destiny one exotics uh tazzy did
one a while back this is from last year
so this will give me an idea and i can
look through
vex is back uh zalo supercell we
basically have risk runner
but we basically have risk runners kind
of a fair competition
yeah uh hawkmoon's back first curse we
basically have hawkmoon we're good on
hawk we're good on hand cannons guys can
we get
other varieties than hand cannons please
i'm i'm good
uh red death we got the hand cannon
version
we got yeah crimson so we kind of no
time to explain
got that now that's one thing there's
you've got fabian strategy to lay lock
if they would do class specific weapons
oh you want classic cigarettes i'm
totally fine with that not everybody
needs to get everything guys that's
like part of how gaming works like i
would love to see some specifics that
really
because that was the thing about delay
lock now granted it was for a very
specific purpose because
you would like never use a super because
you're like well if i die then i'm in
waiting
well now the fact it was one of those
like if you're in that way your gun
fires like a madman i was like that was
cool find some way to like
embrace like each class or do i would
love
to see stuff like that that'd be cool
touch of malice we're not gonna see
unless we get king's fall that's
maybe in which queen like 2023 that's
later
uh boolean gemini that was the old scout
that really never got ahold of the love
yeah they would have to rework it i mean
it was decent
yeah well yeah i remember that one plan
c is basically a backup plan fusion
rifle now so yeah
that's a perk pretty much now we're not
going to get an effect of a rice breaker
because they created amount of thin air
yeah those are no
coming back bungie's never really pocket
infinity
uh there's nothing that you haven't got
to that i think
would be absolutely awesome zen meteor
you know what the one is come on maybe
you're gonna win a no no no no not even
that not even i don't want to because i
do not want that to ever come back no no
even if they nope we got the iron one
back
um yeah i think we're all over
yellowhorse
okay but there's two that i think no but
i want to hear your
your answers uh so we got zen meteor
that's like basically firefly cloud
strike and solar
pick one read them all i'm trying to
look through but i was like um
i have two really good picks but i want
to hear you guys first
you know actually
i mean the exotic swords obviously were
pretty cool mm-hmm
um all right i'll go out now
i'm like i look through all these i'm
like we've seen so many or we have
varieties like
delegation i'm going with to layla
that's fair i gave you that one
i liked it because it operated like a
complete different gun when you had full
super i believe
and um yeah it was unique and it really
i
did it like up the rate of fire rate of
fire yeah it was a beast
it was just absolutely monster when you
had your super full yeah
it had like max stability like fast
reload
faster it was like yeah it was on super
i think the rate of friday went up a
little bit and
i am like i am a person who sort of sits
on my super a lot
i'm guilty of that like i could see
myself like using
well you know the middle tree well
irradiance and you know sometimes you
don't really use it until it's critical
moments
yeah so the other moments you know the
other 70 of the time you're using it
why not have this scout that actually
operates you know kind of like a fascist
so i would say talent
but um e and said because i'm dying to
know what macy's is after you guys
ah like i'm looking through and i listen
to them i'm looking
god damn uh
ah that's not in already
i mean if i can shoot for the gold medal
i'm gonna go for a touch of balance
because that gives me king's fall so
that's a biased opinion
that's my way to get around the question
major rework yeah so that we could use
it outside
the raid but i was like i love the
styling of the weapon the rotation the
clock hanging
over yeah but yeah some way to have the
functionality not kill you
in everything but that one moment in the
raid but that also would get me back
king's fall
sure that'd be my again that's my cheap
answer what are you doing
what's your favorite i got to know you
two two
it's either two okay so one is i love
the smell of napalm in the morning so
i'm going to say i would love to see
dragon's breath yeah i was going to say
this yeah i personally i love rocket
launchers and i use them either code
dulo
i got a great his inventions me too
i got two of them if you get guys uh
chat
if you get the curated uh alters of
sorrow
heretic arc it rolls with uh
demolitionist
and forget what else and cluster bomb
and it's an awesome rocket launcher it's
really really good um
so i so i'd say either dragon's breath
or
breath i would like to see icebreaker
come back i think icebreaker would be a
fun one
the bungee uh sandbox team will
unfortunately is going to have to be
they will shoot that down
yeah i know they just made a conscious
decision
you could you could tell like they don't
want anything when we kind of sit back
so many people agree with you they want
it they want it back but
it's just they are so hell bent on
anything with the regeneration ammo kind
of deal but
i tell you this if they did bring it
back you know
it would that would be one that a lot of
people
some people come back to destiny for
that's how much they love
icebreaker i mean i mean it's beloved
yeah i still remember
back in the day i mean ice break was one
of my first exotics i got and i remember
i bought it from zur and i remember
using it on the top for the templar
where we would cause i'm going to clan
rezo and that's right when i first
joined rezo
and we would all sit up top and we would
just snipe down
on the templar from up top there and you
never had to worry about ammo but you
are right
the ammo economy one would drive the pvp
community crazy
oh and also for pve you're right a lot
of people just camp a spot
and just slowly pick off the boss
forever you know what that thing they
have done everything
they can though rain
fire if you you know if there's a
seasonal artifact mod
that uh you know can um amplify the
uh solar effects for it or anything like
that could you imagine
what mine cell built with oh yes
yeah i know a lot of people are waiting
for aydah to sell the wrath of rasputin
um mods just got done selling range of
the war mine so sorry if you guys missed
that one
yeah no that's that's a yeah that's
always an interesting one to think back
because we've got a little
bit brian brian gamer says i do it's
just that they don't want
uh elemental primaries anymore but zelo
was good man
i love that thing oh yeah for some
reason to me that one still feel
felt better than risk runner risk
runner's not bad and the chain lightning
is cool
but for some reason the way like zayla
because it was an electric ak-47
and for some reason it just had that a
little bit more like
beefy feel to it yeah yeah it's like
something about the way it sounded
always hit me right i agree
you know what i really started to
appreciate risk runner was doing um
what you call it raid a fallen law
sector yeah and the fallout
obviously and um the uh what you call it
uh why am i forgetting to laugh the name
of the last read what's going on with me
space walk and good times keep sound
crypt deep stone crib yeah
hello i actually appreciated it it's
during that during the eight-tracks
fight in certain sections
i was using it there and it was really
effective and that electricity bursting
off because you're fighting just nothing
but fall
oh also one other one patience and time
what's up
invisibility let's go sniping okay okay
okay all right what else we got you just
going
uh well as for destiny
story complete bonkers can't wait to see
what happens
grandmasters they launched this week so
we've got a man who put some time in on
these things i've watched people
struggle painful tweets like it's been
and they kicked it off hardcore they're
like hey you're not good there's no
there's no learning curve glassway
straight away
you want to talk about one that sets up
for a painful grand master so mesa this
is on
this is yours break us down for one
glass way what do you what's the hardest
parts like what are the tough pieces
and then for you like any advice on like
loadouts and stuff like that i'm kind of
curious not a pve
well as as much as i love pve i'm not an
mlg yellow swag pve pro okay that's okay
that's okay
and my boys rob and blackwood um and i
spent about two hours last night so we
both said this is just not
a fun player experience getting up to
the final room
was great okay but bungie
put way too many champions in that final
room that's why i'm looking forward to
next week when it's inside terminus
there's no i believe there's no
champions in the final room so we'll do
grand master
next week inside terminus but um man
just those overloads they just
rush you like crazy you know what i mean
and um to the boss
is is fun it's a lot of fun uh we were
running let's see i i was using stasis
turrets for a while
my two boys rob and blackwood were using
sentinel titans
and um holding the shield up so we're
doing a lot of damage and they were
making orbs like crazy then i switched
over for the like the final two runs to
warlock well
um and solar grenades you know like
when you're trying to cap that one uh
the middle part you know like
because you're just getting rushed
hilariously
yeah and um yeah so for the most part
reaching cleric
came in so anarchy was really good
wither horde was okay
with the horde was amazing okay up until
the f
or at least we found was up until then
the
final room because you had so many
overloads in it
that wither horde is not stunning them
you need
that's when i switched to my extra extra
ordinary rendition
nice s750 smg yeah
my rotation continue and and pro tip
also if you have a fate bringer or
something with
a hand cannon with explosive rounds that
one two two taps
will stun in overload not hits basically
yeah
normal hand cannons it's three shots but
you could get them with two shots with
um
explosive hands you want to know if you
have a little bit of face about that i
have my
fate bringer with firefly if a guy
explodes next to them
that'll lock him down quick like right
then oh really firefly
i actually hit the overload captain
because i was running today is um
uh exodus garden2a i was doing the
master uh lost sector and there's all
the little
like all the thrall and then the one
overload and you can hit the one guy
it explodes and stuns the other ones so
it's just this random thing that
triggers two just random but i doubt
it's
but yeah if you got a fake bringer with
like explosive payload and firefly you
can at least stun some overloads it's
it's viable
so we just found yeah so we i mean and
then at one point like we um
one of us tried the cheese spot and it
was just boring and stuff so we just
kept trying to do it legit and we're
just like we were just getting wasted
you know
like by everything just like it's it's
for um
the final room to have that many
overloads before even the barriers come
out
because you're dealing with not only the
overloads like crazy and they're really
angry
and they you know will rush you and
melee you
and it's a one shot and then two you've
got the boss roaming around and then
you've got his little minion
the little vex hydra roaming around the
hallways too and
he seems like he just will not go away
like you gotta get
his health down so much um for him you
know to go away
so we just tapped out you know and that
was so that's been our
experience we didn't get it done i mean
that's believe me
i'm not even high enough to try yet uh
which goes back to part of
like the living i'm like 13 31 i'm
getting close
between different pinnacles and you know
the artifact grind and stuff like that
but as i'm not just like
no lifeing it for a season if you play
your tuesdays and you do some other
stuff
my artifacts not that high it's really
not yeah you in the same boat i think
what's happening to me is
i've been so focused with the story my
end game has been
focused no yeah do you think my end game
has been
focusing more on kind of god rolls for
now that i've unlocked that
like i've been focusing on doing the
corrupted version of expunge
to get yeah the dual perk yep and i'm
loving what is the ignition code i'm
working on ignition code
chroma rush um which is the 720
and then um grid skipper so those are
the three
i'm trying to get better god rolls kind
of thing what i really want
is blinding grenade for the uh it's
called blinding grenade
vorpal because i don't actually like
i actually like blinding nade over or
spike
in a weird way because i like that when
you shoot them they kind of put their
head it almost acts like safe helmets
a14
you know they put their hands over their
eye the enemy and it adds they don't
fire back and they don't shoot
yeah i kind of like that effect and then
vault will for the extra damage if it is
a boss or something like that so that's
the one i'm rolling i'm trying to
roll with and especially it works good
with preaching clear oh dude
and then unstoppable you know like
grenade launches this season is it's
awesome
yeah between breach and clear grenade
launcher scavenger being cheap yeah and
then you've also gone
if unstoppables on dude i have oh
it's so like salvager salvo for the win
all day long but you also got
empty vessel you've got that one as a
solar version which is cool
um depending on what the burn is unlike
there are so many ways to handle like
the legend law sectors this season and
master as well
it's like yeah the breach and clear is
huge if you can find some way to get
that the damage bonuses are huge and
they just stack up like if i can go
salvage or salvo and a burn with solar i
went salvagers to set up bridge and
clear
solar burn xenophage
oh just absolutely destroyed yeah so
it's been hard for me to take salvage of
salvo out because with the chain
especially with interactions chain
reaction energy accelerant one on the
one that oh yeah
yeah yeah oh like that now you know what
give me mando
bungie why i ain't letting me do breach
it clear and energy accelerate together
yeah cause it technically costs 11.
and i'm like come on budgie let me have
that man i want to blow things up
and reach it clear but not you're right
you're right i mean
it is it's really fun running that man
but yeah so my
end game like i was saying before which
is more so now that i've unlocked that
part of the
the corrupted expunge thing and and and
doing those so i can get the double
i love double perk weapons having that
option
so i'm still farming my mission code
because i want that you know one that i
want that i told you waffle
blinding grenade chroma
so much better than i thought it should
there's so much aim assistant i think it
locks on the targets
yeah loving that and and i'm gonna front
grip
grid skipper a what what is it uh
heating up
in any combination of either rampage or
something i just i need a good
combo so that's where i'm at you know
what about what about you as far as your
is it has your message has your thing
been like the grand
masters or you're still doing other
things override what's your main
loop this i'm obsessed with the vault of
glass
i mean even if we if i don't need
anything from it i can do that thing
over and over if people want to do it
and
have a fun time with it because for me
you know
it comes back to the player experience
you know
so for me you know at first it was a
struggle figuring out how we do
how are we going to do the call outs you
know what i mean so i feel a sense of
accomplishment when i get the callouts
right
you know what i mean and it's you know
times vengeance
and then we you know get you know
because finally less you know because
we're you know like you build up your
momentum over
the course of weeks and you you know
fine-tuned things and stuff so finally
last week we too faced them you know
until then we're always you know just
kind of three-phasing them you know yeah
but you know just being able to
you know um get it down so that okay
i finally spotted or heard the sound on
the side of the screen
where it said being detained get out of
there you know what i mean or the person
who gets detained
you know there is a cute little feature
which i don't know how to do but
supposedly
you could stop atheon from detaining
someone
if you go at a certain time when he's
about to put his foot down or something
or get him
do a foot stop he's still okay like stop
something
well he detains at exactly 15 seconds or
something like that so
okay there's a way that if you stagger
i'm talking out of my butt right now so
it could be perhaps because on my titan
i like to run the um
what do you call it the superman thing
uh oh thunder crash was curious with the
falling start yeah
yeah so i i think maybe i don't know
chat let us know if you hit him right at
the 15 second mark he might not detain
someone but i know there's something you
could do there
with that you know but okay vaulted
glass you know like the templar killing
him in 15 seconds with
our double slugs rolling in spoils right
now
oh well no because i burned them all on
terabot because i never got terrible
yeah i gotta do i have to do the exact
same thing that's the only one i ever
got yeah
that's the only one i don't have either
and the only piece of gear i'm missing
is the warlock helmet which i really
want to get
badly oh you mean yeah for the for the
rate itself okay yeah yeah for the raid
itself
the vaccine of the class i got on my
fifth run and
i got the catalyst done that night
because
like that's how great the community is
so there's a destiny 2 pc lfg
on discord i jumped in there there was
other guys looking to do it and they
were pve pros boy
nice and we knocked it out and fun
little factoid do you guys remember in
the whisper of the worm mission
you'd find the portal and when you look
through the portal you could see into
the vaulted glass
absolutely when you do the vex catalyst
when the catalyst drops
that portal is open again and when you
look through it you could see
you could see that through the head dude
that's such a cool touch
like that yeah and like i know everyone
likes to s
on vex right now i'm saying with my my
build that i run with
taking charge quick charge stacks on
stacks
um i forget i made a whole video you can
conveniently watch
try this now absolutely it's a vex smith
class build because i don't have it just
off the top of my head but
you get an 80 you know bonus damage to
it and i i don't use it for end game
content no but for running override and
stuff and trash mobs or
regular strikes or even regular
nightfalls or even some lost sector well
no i'm i'm not going to use it most
actors but expunge i'm going to use vex
method class it's fun you know outbreak
sitting out
a little bit i still miss wow
your legendary outbreak prime minister
part of it's a little bit of a flex
because i want to walk around the tower
but i will say that do you guys remember
the season when you had anti-barrier
pulse
and an outbreak perfected with shred
through barrier champions it was so nice
again
but that's the beauty of bungie changing
up the artifacts because
look we thought or at least i did uh
oppressive darkness
it couldn't get any better than that
right good point and then bungie goes
and drops breaching clear on us yeah
like for end game content like with
anarchy or
like you said salvation salvo or any
grenade launcher
and just seeing that next season and
just how you need one person to hit that
you're like you don't need all
you know everyone running you know
breaching clear you just need one person
you know
um what a great great you know like the
way they're mixing up the seasonal
artifact um
you could tell bungie's evolving you
know because this one i think
probably do i dare say it has been the
best season artifact in terms of
the mods that you can mix and match from
yeah i still want them to let me unlock
be
let me unlock more of them because
i don't really set it without cost yeah
i hate the cost of resetting them
is just useless yeah and then let me
reset it and just reset and pick diff
like if you want to limit so i can't
unlock everything that's your like magic
mo
fine but reset should be free
i know and that and how you have to do
one column and then pray that you could
finally
you know what i mean yes unlocked
because like i will never unlock i think
in the first column it's unstoppable
sidearm i never use that i love devil's
ruin guys i don't like you guys
i love it because one for unstoppables
it will waste them
two just regular yellow bars from
from even medium range it just just
watched your health go from
like that you know what i mean that it's
a really good sidearm you know i love
that thing and i don't like sidearm so
that speaks volumes yeah that's big yeah
shout out to sparkle he said they should
let us reset the artifact like
outriders does with no cost to respect
yes
screams there's no wrong hunter in the
house how you doing spark control yeah
man
long time channel member thanks for
being here buddy yeah no he's right man
yeah if you can it just i don't i could
see bungie changing that
because i mean like what's the point
then i gotta go to the spider to get
glimmer
yeah it's like it's not it's not
it is adding nothing to the game that's
just
yeah that would need to be fixed so no
um
nightfalls are definitely a thing but
the builds i mean the artifact this
season has been
a lot of fun to goof around with
and but grenade launchers man they have
made them
just a must use as much as if i can find
a way to put one on my
character it's on there i don't care
where yeah if i can find a way it's
definitely there
so unstoppable grenade launcher too
that's
that's a fun it's a lot of fun stuff you
could do a grenade launcher and then
in the this week in bungie isn't love
and death coming back because that was
my
channel i was just getting to that yep
so yeah okay i'm sorry
i'm literally looking at them right now
so yeah they're gonna be
the patch coming yeah perfect segway um
july 6th the patch that they're working
on the next one coming up they are
working on reissuing basically the rest
of both the moon and the dreaming city
weapons
so we've got our arsenal's about to get
a little bigger so for the moon you've
got quite a few you got loud lullaby
and they have basically they state all
of these weapons will drop from their
original sources
of their respective destination here's a
full list of the weapons along with an
example of new perks they can each roll
with and it's this example probably not
an exhaustive list so hopefully we have
a little more variety in perks
uh you've got loud lullabies so it's
your big 120 with tunnel vision
uh 120 i want you to go through it yeah
120 hand cannon
uh you got one small step that's going
gonna be your shotgun with trench barrel
okay tranquility should be your sniper
if i remember correctly with frenzy
arc logic to your auto arc auto with
heating up
is it is is art was archer 720 what was
our it was really fast
firing it might have been i remember
that it might have been a 600
or 720. remember it was a decent i mean
i made my 720 love phase it's like
it's not that fast i don't think it's
that fast if it's 720 i'm getting
excited i mean 600 is still good but i
hope it is
big d 600 all right all right the crash
says i'm ready
i buy six six hours is still good uh
dream breaker
uh that's gonna be fusion rifle it's got
cornered so that new perk we've seen on
a couple of the fusions
every waking moment that's killing wind
i don't specifically remember what that
one is
love and death that's your grenade
launcher with chain reaction hello
oh nice yep yeah and i think it wrote
with spike grenades it can roll with uh
full court and i think that's the one i
remember
yeah and field prep too that thing was i
love that thing
and that with breaching clear i'm
definitely farming for that sadly i
basically had a god roll loving death
and it's
gone but what are you gonna do yeah a
fine memorial
that's gotta be like a machine gun i
don't remember adrenaline junkie i don't
honestly remember what that one is and
night terror
uh that's a sword and it's got one for
all for dreaming city we're basically
getting our final misses we've got tiger
spike coming with frenzy
that's that's
that thing was amazing yeah let's go
uh and then we've got twilight oath
which
so many people enjoy sniping with coming
with vorpal
so that's going to make some spicy
either super shots or
boss damage even though snipers on
bosses just don't do it anymore
and by the return you got thresh on a
sword
so good variety on both but i mean the
moon has
the minimum shadow key there's a whole
damn expansion now we're getting one two
three four
five six seven eight nine weapons there
and we're getting
mid season we're getting 12 new weapons
basically so that's
that's literally mid season we're
getting a nice little influx of weapons
so i mean
they said they were taking some time to
it takes time for them to
build up and train new employees but
they're getting to the point where they
can really
you know reissue these things put them
back in stuff like that and hopefully if
these are getting reissues to kind of
give more variety to the sandbox when it
comes to the next season and then witch
queen we're going to have
even obviously bigger influxes of
weapons so
excited to see what comes there for sure
yeah that's good that's good to see
uh iron banner returns again it's been a
week
yeah so this is one
this is not a big topic the fact that
iron banner is coming back
more of the topic of this is week seven
week eight if you go look at the
calendar he knows where i'm going with
this one
we have expunge we're gonna have the
corrupted
tartarus so that's the last corrupted
supposedly there's one more
i'm not gonna say anything but just
supposedly there's one we have to face
quarry at some point
don't know how or where that's something
but outside of that
solstice and iron banner is the rest of
your season and i feel like it's gonna
be iron man
they said one other so you're probably
going to take a break after solstice but
man i feel like you could do this iron
banner every other week right now
but this leads into season 15.
i want to see if we can go an over under
on how many iron banners we're gonna
have before which clean
like six seven eight how many iron
banners do you guys expect
in season 15 before witch queen are
you implying that there's a content drop
an iron banner is using to
be used as a plant this lack of cocktail
that's what we're implying i'm 100
yes for season 15 because we know
there's a delay
that's why right so i'm kind of curious
i know we're going to have
a festival lost that'll be a couple
weeks two or three
uh you're going to have donning
they'll definitely not do it during that
time that's their break
but i mean you have august 24th say even
through february
picking up i just wanted to get you guys
guess how many do you think because i
mean we've had three
four this one might be five this season
for iron banners if i think correctly
so what you think basically how are we
going to get nine or it could be nine or
ten i think at this point you know what
i mean
but you know what if they look if bungie
because i know i believe they're back in
the studios now right
it should be hopefully don't know if
they are they actually probably could be
i guess cause some of the developers
tweeted
pictures of them outside the studio and
then uh christopher barrett tweeted out
a picture of
lars yes that's right scott taylor which
you clearly could tell they were
i think my opinion they were filming a
vidoc i think we're getting a witch
queen viadok this summer
and start hyping things up so what i'm
hoping is
throw you know because one of the player
experiences i missed from destiny 1 was
i loved iron banner because of so many
weapons and i look forward to
reaching that end and popping all those
packages and seeing what i got because
and then also the fact that um lady
efforty always sold
god rolls and how i use destiny item
manager would tell you
you know 99 stat roll or you know 100
so i'd always grind my ass off to get
those rolls and stuff so
if they could introduce some more
weapons you know and also
if they could get rid of the haunted
forest um
i am so sick of the haunted forest my
dream is this
uh okay i love the european aerial zone
okay
my dream my dream is a haunted european
aerial zone okay
you know what i mean just to mix it up a
little bit you know but i would be okay
with that would give it up
for this yeah because i mean like the
haunted yeah
yeah just an idea bungie by the way
numerous times i wanted to shout out dcp
for their
charity marathon stream that they did
for oh yeah um so they
raised 76 000 and
which was fan freaking tastic amazing
nice they were
their last hour is worth a watch like if
you have time just throw that last hour
on
fallout eats like a um
hot wing what is the damn show what's
the youtube show
the wingding yeah what is the damn last
dab
he eats yeah hot ones he eats the last
dab
like number 10 he eats one of those
goes for two he leaves
mercury's comes in not a big fan of
spice
goes straight in on a habanero just like
almost face almost shuts down
shout out to work and then fallout comes
back for a third
if they hit a certain threshold but the
best of all
almost all of dcp is hunter to the core
our aries your modernist areas is in
chat shadows
shout out his new name for the year
shout out mr holly madness your second
um
but that whole crew
now has to play their least favorite
subclass for all of season
15. they're oh my god warlocks for the
longest season
ever oh my god i love it let's go
can you just why the warlock case
i think that's why i wasn't invited
if you guys see ares if you guys see any
of those guys playing
make sure they're made in that warlock
because you know they didn't they did it
for the little ones but
i think they're going to be dying inside
for a long time now
i think basically it's just it's it's
snobby
no no they're jealous they're just
jealous because we were the ones
self-resting their asses
uh in destiny one okay and this and that
you know i mean we're always providing
support and we look the we dressed up we
missed
the best face it we dress the best just
go
love it but using those big arms that
come out to hear in the connect you know
what i mean
hey i can take a missile to my ship i
can take a missile in my shoulder pad
over here and i'll be fine
there your focus this season just
dressed in me you're good but i wanted
to shout out dcb because aries was in
here but because i have two warlocks
that enjoy their subclass i wanted to i
had to shout out the other side it was
too funny
that's so funny i love it they're so
upset
i love it man he said you're going to
play warlock for your season now brother
you got to embrace your inner floof
floof race to space
magic exactly get the space magic on man
let's go that's funny that's good that's
it yeah
that would okay i gotta catch that last
night like it's a four-hour stream it's
on there and just like skip to the last
hour
worth it totally hilarious
but yeah like so as for this season
we're sitting here at a point to where
hal
i wanted to ask you guys like i know
you're playing vault a lot um
and then cog i wanted to see like what
are you guys thoughts once we kind of
how much you know between now and witch
queen
is what are you guys looking forward to
the most
between now and which queen what do you
guys want to see answered because witch
queen is going to be big
which queen could be even we'll get
there in a minute but like what are you
guys looking forward to between now
and which queen the most be it this
season or 15 anything you're looking
forward to anything hyped about
i mean you know for me it's just more of
the narrative payoff i just want to know
where they're going like there's still a
little confusion like
you know what's gonna happen and how
they set it up and then to me
i'll be honest you know what the biggest
thing i'm curious about
what the hell is epilogue dude
what the hell is that like that's like i
think it's gotta be the live event dude
that's gotta be it feels like you read
my
i was like epilogue so to me
that sets up when i hear that i feel
change i feel some type of
transformative action and i think mace
is
100 on the money i think that's we
probably do
for a live event last one we had was
what was when um
the what you call the almighty traveler
well the almighty came and then you had
the traveler light up
darkness gonna take over that was not as
big
traveler was big bright light you know
kind of reforming right
yeah that piece yeah i i my gut says
if they really want the stakes to be
high
we got to have a we got to have an
avengers infinity war
moment where the heroes look grim
they lost and i think you set it up
somehow with either a sabbath
reveal something where you're like oh no
this has happened right and to me that's
how you transition
into the eventual which cream where you
know we we kind of get up off our feet
and
we try to round up what that whether it
be mission two of destiny two
that music man talk about it talk about
it right
so it's like yeah man i would love i'm
putting a lot of pressure on the story
team but they're doing such a good job
like i need an infinity war moment
you know what i'm saying i don't feel
that good mr stark something needs to
happen
something needs that when we feel it and
we go
oh yo this is this is serious somebody's
at the tower getting blown up again
it's something like sabbath doom reveal
takes the life of somebody or something
very tragic happens
and we go oh no we gotta get payback
this is we gotta you know we gotta
lace our boots up unified front you know
and do it that's what i'm hoping
epilogue that's a lot of pressure i'm
putting but what do you guys think like
what what is
your most anticipated thing for the
season masonry
i'm praying for okay so from two
perspectives one is gonna be loot and
one is going to be
okay salute and activities okay and then
from the story narrative so
for me from the player experience what i
am praying and hoping on
is that the witch queen is the taken
king of destiny 2.
yeah okay because remember when the
trailers came out
for the taken king right it was so
ominous
that something horrible was happening
right
that all of a sudden everything's
hunky-dory we killed the god and
everything and that
then all of a sudden this fleet of ships
come out of nowhere
because their son oryx's son was killed
in this and that
and this narrative came along and he's
coming back and he's really pissed off
and this and that
and even when you've when you first
logged into taking king
whenever you would float and we still
hear the music now because he put it
back in
when you would float in air you would
hear this ominous music that you knew
something horrible was in the solo
system that's the narrative i want a
doom and gloom thing that yeah
something horrible is coming
in the witch queen and that we got to
prepare ourselves as guardians
to face whatever it's going to be in
this synapse so that's that's kind of
the st like the story that is like to
get us really really scared
as to what's going to something terrible
is going to happen and that it's gonna
shake up
everything that we possibly know about
being a guardian
being part of the vanguard whatever
happens with factions or anything like
that or the tower
from the loop perspective i really hope
for the next season we get a really fun
activity
and lots of loot that's going to keep us
look
we burn through content guys we're
destiny fans right
that's what we do generally i just
really hope that they can keep us
um safe is that the right word
associated
throughout the season with lots of loot
and
whether it's reissues or or new guns but
lots of stuff to keep
us occupied until the witch queen you
know comes out
so two fronts that really frightening
narrative that not something good is
happening something scary
is happy because i still go back and get
it's it's corny as hell i don't care but
i get chills watching those
king trailers yeah when you know there's
like the mini one where it's like you
know
orex is coming to get you guardian you
killed his son
you know what i mean and then also you
see the ship you see the dreadnought and
you see all the ships you know like
flying in
you know and then oh my god and then you
know like seeing
um aldrin you know yes you know like the
queen
flying back and forth dude they should
have star wars from the you know like
the original trilogy fights you know i
mean like
those cut scenes were in sanity and then
you know like the thing you know like um
marisov does like whatever she does and
this huge explosion hits
and causes a crater in you know like the
asteroid belt or whatever
that's the narrative i want for next
season now
give it a give it to us bungee
next season is cross play so that's one
that will be huge for literally the
entire community because
those times were like hey i want to run
a raid i want to do this that the
does it if you know anyone anywhere who
plays this game you'll now be able to
say
hey you know this game it's for one it's
free to play you want to jump in
catch back up it's going to be that time
and i think that's one of those
i think that's one of those moments
that's really going to help bring so
many things together
just across playstation xbox and pc and
just try and like get everybody on one
kind of united front because it's no
longer going to be
especially well yeah i don't know if
i've literally if i've played destiny
yeah we haven't played since pc and then
now especially with xbox you're like i'm
back there and now it's not going to
matter because your controller so you'll
go back easy i can't get off pc because
i suck
i am terrible with the controller at
shooting so i will leave that to you too
that's fine
but that's gonna be the awesome part
it's like hey you're on xbox you got
friends over there
just still drink him in drag him into my
party and still go raid whatever you
want to do
you just like hey do you want the last
word play doesn't matter
like it's so so nice that's a big one
i'm looking forward to
for just functionality and also ps5 has
discord right
it's working on it it's not yeah yeah
yeah they did the partnership but i know
it's like
yeah they did the playstation
partnership i don't think it's like
integrated yet i
i'm with you amazing i would love that
integration right yes
because all of us on pc use discord i
have a lot of close friends that i used
to play with on playstation 4
that i think they might have migrated to
ps5s i think so
i would love to be able to play with
them again and my you know my other new
friends and
some channel members that i play with on
pc and stuff like that um
it's people need to know it is opt in or
out right because that because i know
the pvp community is going to lose
i think it'll be like if your parent
yeah it's some type of opt-in or you'll
have the choice or
if you just join somebody on pc i'm sure
there's going to be some like
so hey you're about to join somebody on
pc we're opening you know your match
making something like that's gonna have
to be there
yeah cause for pve i think it's gonna be
totally fine for pvp
there's gonna be issues because i don't
know you guys but since i play i'll okay
if people think cheating on pc
in trials is bad try warzone okay
every i forgot someone said that there
was some percentage of how many people
in every war zone game are indeed
hacking every night we run into hackers
and cheaters or aimbots or
wall hacks where i'm like there's no way
this guy knew that i was
behind this one wall and somehow he
magically knew
his smack 10 and domed you know what i
mean so but yeah that's the big problem
um
and i also hope bungie rolls out more
anti-cheat things and i'm not a
developer so i don't know how difficult
it is
i mean because activision i mean i don't
know
they've been banning a lot of people
because every time we suspect that we're
getting cheated on we just
you have a little button on your
controller i think it's l3 that you can
report you know
the player but that's the problem with
pc is there's a lot of cheating you know
for pvp
it it's going to be brutal but for pve i
think it's going to be great
yes yeah pve it'll be a godsend for
everybody to be like
just doesn't yeah because i mean pvp and
that was the cool thing did you guys do
the match the cross play playlist did
you do the couple strikes you could do
yeah yeah it was it literally was
effortless
i literally because like nothing changed
i don't know if i got paired with pc i
didn't know i don't know who and i think
that was the point
yeah like if it if they can manage to
integrate it that well i was like
that's amazing because if cross play
there's some games that get it right
some that haven't yet but if they can
make it utterly
just like you don't even know it's there
that's gonna be so big i honestly think
that
you know i know we we all complain a
little bit with the content drought
sometimes and
we look at the fact that which queen is
delayed so they're gonna have to buffer
with
how many iron banners they're gonna
buffer but they're gonna have to extend
content right
but i will say cross play is going to be
a nice band-aid during that time yes
all right because the communities can
come together because bro i got so many
people i feel bad because that i went
back
to you know series x and and playing on
console full-time
you know that some some of my guys
that's in ironworld podcast clan
that are on pc can't get raid groups all
together
and like damn we miss you know hanging
with the homies and just talking and
you know so it's gonna be cool to kind
of reunite the communities again and
then there's so many guys on playstation
you know that i've never played destiny
with and i'm you know
either big fans of theirs or you know
they watch us and stuff so it's gonna be
a fun moment
to to get the communities together and
that's the part i'm really
looking forward to i think that's really
really cool so i think that'll be a nice
little band-aid to
to help us through that drought so to
speak yeah i mean you'll have a couple
live
you'll have the seasonal events and
stuff like that but i think that is
something they probably
not in a bad way but they are going to
crutch on it pretty hard because i've
heard some people saying it's like hey
it's like going to be as a
you know eight month season we need an
extra season i'm like there's no way in
hell they're gonna take resources away
to try and build another season just to
take stuff away from witch queen i'm
like it is gonna be
some down time but guess what the
holidays are they're jam-packed full of
other games so you're gonna
have a ton of games yeah oh that's right
yeah i mean like whenever horizon hits
that's one halo another one xbox just
lined up their end of the year
like you've got so much coming down the
pipeline for
games that are finally in the
playstations probably in about what
three weeks or so everybody thinks is
going to be talking about theirs
to know what's going to be coming on
that front so we've got a lot to look
forward to so that's again one of those
times where
enjoy the tuesdays because they're not
going to make like a 20 week campaign
it's not going to be that long it's
going to be you know 9 or 10 weeks kind
of like this one and then we are going
to have some downtime so it's like enjoy
it
cross play when you can but that's going
to be the time to get out there but for
the other side of things for like witch
queen i'm yeah you guys are right like
the live event setting up the dominoes
the quote from so long ago
savathune i i think you said i think
mesa i think you said
i want the traumatic dark something
major
to happen to really shake the player
base like story-wise to their core to be
like
i mean it's one of those two if like
they you know osiris walks up behind
zaval and like stabs in the back the
back like
something major you're like holy just
like yeah like the ruse is over yeah i'm
sorry
no but that's exactly the level that i
would love to see because those are the
points when the story is some of the
best
is when we get those major things like
i'd never want kade to come back
because of how that felt now granted i
got a little spoiled but like the fact
that we lost kade like
beloved i mean those types of things so
something on that level is what i can
hope for
to give witch queen it's like the john
wick motivation
nobody likes the first 10 minutes of
that movie but it set off six hours of
amazing action that john wick was pissed
off because somebody killed his dog and
it's like
you touch my dog everybody's gonna die
and it's like and it's that thing
it's like if you can cross that line
it'd be something so bad like what would
i mean could you imagine if osir if
osiris stabbed saint
um vanguard
some type of major backstabbing and some
of these are all
likely not possible because the voice
actors are probably a little too locked
in but
it needs to be something big and that's
the thing it could be something
as simple as all season it was like the
build-up of
the pyramids coming before arrivals you
know
something just like it was and again i'm
relating look the taken king
scenario worked really well something is
entering
the solar system and all season long
either weird things start happening
on various destinations right
and then all of a sudden uh the vanguard
scouts or um i chorus hidden
start detecting transmissions outside
our solar system
if something is arriving and it's coming
and it's slowly
you know sky boxes start changing you
know kind of like how when the pyramids
you know like showed up
and yeah i would love that just that
morbid that something terrible
is coming setting up an ominous like an
ominous season just like starting to
like
shift all the pieces in place and
everywhere we look it's just looking bad
yeah i could yeah that'd be a subtle way
to set up something kind of cool i could
get behind that without like
you know treacherous murder or something
like that i think the ominous setup
would be or like something like okay
like something like 7th dune is so
powerful that like um
i don't know if bungie would be willing
to do this or something like that but it
gets so bad that literally
the tower is you can't inhabit it you
know
and then all of a sudden all the vendors
at the tower because of all these
horrible things that have come to our
solar system because of
the vengeance of savathun you know
they're all spread out all over the
place now and it's not because
and we have to over the course of the
witch queen seasons
you know either get everyone back to the
tower or somehow rebuild the tower
again or something like that uh just
something really just
some i just want something because
didn't okay wasn't it news that
bungie was either looking for or hired
someone from the resident evil franchise
yes yes that that was especially in
charge of like
horror or mormon type stuff like yeah
that made me think like dude you know
like for a narrative that could be the
narrative
to go down that dark road you know what
i mean like something real scary
ominous evil i'm with you yeah i got my
theory too
if they that sounds awesome i got i want
if they do this i mean this is probably
not gonna happen because based on
bungie's history but i kind of want like
this whole
sleeper agent kind of vibe right so
anybody who
have heard savithoon's song or has been
influenced right we know crow is in
there singing it in the helm right
so like what i want is like almost like
a snap of the finger
execute order 66 yeah i want to execute
all the 66
so i want everybody now that's been mind
control and now
the guardian is also the enemy and the
ones who are not influenced
are overrun like you said either have to
get out the tower do something
like i will shout out to the cops come
on i'm live by a lot block i apologize
but at the end of the day they're
excited too at the end of the day it's
like i want that thing where it's like
oh
yo like you know crow you know whoever's
in
size all the people under the influence
and it's almost like a zombie thing or
whatever and they gotta get out of there
whether it be a cory zavala because it
is just
utmost chaos and you have to kind of go
against your own that that's another
thing that would be cool
i don't know if they did is they never
really done guardian versus guardian
kind of stuff
but it would be interesting i think that
would be you know there's some sort of
mass
evacuation of the tower i don't know if
they could have a switch to tower to
first-person mode but what if there was
like one
specific mission that was like leading
into where the tower becomes first
person right you know what i mean and
you have a mission inside the tower all
over it and stuff like that where
you know it's an evacuation and uh that
ends up with some sort of fight i don't
know
i'm just spitting out right now almost
like a d2
when golf came right when the cabal came
yeah we had the tower mission right
yeah yeah it was being destroyed the
last city yeah
yeah a lot of potential a lot of
potential but i was like i think that
kind of tells
what they've been doing the last few
seasons setting it's it's taken a long
time to get here obviously it's seven
years and all this stuff and
it took from you know year two of
destiny one to get to a point now in
year
eight we're going to be talking about
savathun so it's been a while in the
making
but i think as you guys have said it's
like destiny's learned a ton these past
few seasons especially have been
how well they've been telling stories if
like this type of story is telling that
we get now
going into something the size of a witch
queen expansion
dude i can't wait for that yeah that's
that's the level of storytelling that
i'm just gonna like sitting back here
like
yeah sit back in your chair and just
absorb like
whoa they're on fire the key is like if
they just gotta pay it off because
they're doing it they gotta start paying
some stuff off and and to you i know
your team um
you know kingsville do that little
king's fall
legacy content the season before so you
get the hype train going
back next season you don't think i mean
i should bring it back soon when you
think they'll bring it back
they would use the way they used vault
of glass as just a
raid to fill space this season
that is 2020 spring season that's or
2023 through
to spring season i don't expect to
stretch it out
okay no that's interesting i mean it
would it ties into the hive
more yeah this season was like vex and
stuff like that going on so we've got
some other things
i picture that that's a cash cow though
you throw that low
i look is it dead lord if it was next
season
it's cuz it's so fast yeah yeah they
don't they're they're about to
realize again we already saw that they
took away deep stone crips pinnacle
status
yeah so it's like if you do that to
vault of glass then you shoot it in the
foot and then you run out of stuff to
bring in yeah no that
was like my guess that's like you know
what what the hell is it going to be so
we're in season 15
16 17 18 is where i would put that
because 16 would be witch queen 18 is
where i'm going to bet king's
if it's coming it's there that's my bet
what if they really
threw us for a loop and next season
everything is based around
siva and all of a sudden siva makes its
comeback
and what a convenient time to bring back
wrath
you know
i have out the window because dear god i
mean could you imagine
i mean i i i personally rise of iron was
one of my favorite
you know favorite experiences because
you know the uh plaguelands you had
yeah i mean one of the most fun raids
man it was so much fun you know what i
mean i remember
you know it's like i think that would
break where we're heading
but it would be a curveball i wouldn't
expect i can tell you that but i think
it would break where some of this is
heading because
the only one way i could see that and
this is a huge stretch but i don't see
it
would be some way to incorporate
rasputin
back into our avengers lineup yeah
that's the only way i can
eat him like that would be a way to
bring him back in but it also it seems
it seems strange but like that would be
a way to bring him back in but also see
it as a stretch it would be yeah i would
have no idea it's coming i can tell you
that would be a surprise but
as we're leaning into savathun it feels
like if they do that it would be later
yeah
listen they got a lot of content they
can bring back to the legacy vault man
yeah yes i'm excited i'm excited man a
lot of a lot of stuff they could do
yeah well you got anything else [ __ ]
for me i think we had yeah i think we we
hit a lot of the major stuff
and um dude just like i said i'm excited
to see narratively and and where this
thing goes because they
they got us on the edge of our seat and
it it's fun it shout out to them because
we've always wanted this moment
from bungie we know this law was great
you know from d1 we knew it was great
but it was just a matter of putting it
together cohesively
and saying okay you know and now that
they're doing it and knocking it out the
park so i just want that
a good payoff where is this going yeah
and let's do it
yeah it's the cool thing um we get witch
queen
and we're not done we know there's two
more years so as
as big as we hope which queen is it's
the start of the end
which is it's not it's i don't believe
that dude
you don't believe there is look
lightfall and one more
that's what i remember i thought they
said i think
basically my personal opinion is as long
as people play this game
i think they're gonna still make it
because i feel like i could have sworn
there was an interview or so
with i think it was a japanese magazine
or something where they still have
future stories to tell
yeah past lightfall and stuff like that
because i know a lot of the audiences
think at least my audience think okay
life falls over
there they got this hundred million
dollars from that ease they're making
matters like they're getting rid of them
yeah that oh they're going to end the
franchise no like
that no no no all i'm saying is like oh
okay my bad
like the light and the dark saga would
kind of wrap with like
year 10 theoretically is kind of what
they said from the beginning but also
as you at you said that like they've got
more stories that they want to tell in
the universe
that's a point where i see them going
through next-gen
yeah because honestly i mean that's the
thing is like right now
on the way i see this like they're gonna
they've supported last gen for so long
previously i expect them to do that for
the last three years because it is like
you know i they're probably gonna go for
a very long time with last gen because
it helps
support them they have the free-to-play
model they have a big base that's going
to do that
people don't upgrade for a while so i
mean they know their numbers to know how
long they're going to support it
and if this completes this saga it's not
like hey year 10 next gen only it's like
when they get that close to a finish
line now like
destiny fill in the blank what's after
two
and whatever comes after lightfall yeah
i would love to see them go full
next-gen at that point with a new
piece of destiny whether it's legacy
like what it's like in the golden age or
something far beyond what happens
yeah keep this they could keep the world
or something i mean like what if they
did a prequel
you know what i mean completely
different powers you know just thinking
out loud
you know you know i have jar jar binks
in there you know
no hey eric eric's would be
hey mason no
you and um you and eric's need to talk
because he is a
he is a jar jar binking's fantastic
i'm not a fan of jar jar don't get me
wrong actually and after seeing the last
star wars because i am a star wars
fanatic junkie but to me
i don't like any of the new ones okay um
to me even the prequels even as bad as
they are i think are still better than
new ones right
because they still fit the narrative of
the original holy trilogy that i grew up
on
yeah random side
oh travis would just go off right now
let me ask you this he's just
another show i am a filthy star wars
casual
right i'm with you because i'm ogo like
you
so we like the old stuff right but
how did i i really liked mandalorian oh
mandalorians
fantastic i was gonna say hi you know
they say they like beer i never saw it
i never saw it dude if you like star
wars even half as much as it sounds like
you do go watch the mandalorian
hundred percent i am a casual i think it
is the most amazing thing is ever done
oh yes yes go i've been watching
what you've been watching i don't watch
too much tv but if i i haven't
sopranos i watch for the millionth time
again
okay that sounds like i watched over and
over okay
and then uh i'm back on dexter again
because i love dexter i love
i'm obsessed with moving to miami one
day and
they're coming out with season ten yeah
they were trying to
show you what he's been up to since he
left so you know trying to tee that up
with
yeah so but i need to check out the
mandalorian yeah
yeah man delorean yeah please
the the intro alone
you love the music don't you oh it takes
me to a place yeah
that's like playing like a question yeah
turn on disney plus for like one month
honestly what you got okay disney plus
for a month if you can depending on how
much time you have you might
have to go two months you got two
seasons of mandalorian and if you like
any of the marvel movies you got
uh one division captain or falcon winner
so
he's out and then loki we're in the
middle of right now so like you've got
turned on for like a month or two
total money's worth right there but
mandalorian yes
welcome you have to check it out yeah if
you like star wars at all it is worth
every every minute of that it's well
well done
no doubt no doubt uh i got distracted i
think we were trying to wrap this thing
up but we
yeah we're trying to wrap it up sorry no
no no that's good
uh emotional about mandalorians
just mandalorian just hit different it
was well done i really like the way they
david filioni i think is his name the
guy who did
all of the clone wars and stuff like
that he is yes
the i will say the way he explains if
you can ever go find
it's like the second episode when
they're talking about building the
mandalorian and it's
him talking about what he thought about
duel of the fates
do you know what i'm talking about the
way he describes
what the duel of the fates means
like made me appreciate that to another
level
it took the explanation of like duel of
the fates
and it's the it's the fate of anakin bro
it's shout out yeah it it is absolutely
like one of the i was like i will never
look at that movie the same
so amazing so yeah like the mandalorian
and i'll try and find the interview
somewhere but it's um it's the interview
with david filoni it's like a two-minute
clip
him talking about what duel of the fates
means you just like i can't see the
movie the same like you can't look at
the prequels as you said you can't look
at the prequels the same it's
it's something else so no what he's his
passion for
his passion for star wars is basically
what kevin feige has
done with marvel yeah um yeah
shout out to favreau though shout out to
oh favorite two both of those together
he's from where i grew up flushing
queens man
yeah that's where i grew up yeah david
foley i'm sorry i'm pronouncing it wrong
but yeah
his passion for star wars is real and
the stories he's working on telling has
been great so
no that that two and a half minute
little clip i'll try and post it after
we get done so find me on twitter yeah
so yeah you've got to send that to me so
you have to yeah i'll tag you on it it's
so good um but yeah at this point
i think that's i think we've speculated
and hyped enough of what we're hoping
for in the future so
yeah the future of destiny like it may
have its ups and downs but man the
future could be so so bright at this
point like
uh i'm excited so at this point as we
wrap things up
first off want to say mesa thank you man
for joining us tonight
thank you guys so much for having me on
guys let's definitely do this again
sometime this is a lot of fun
we we definitely appreciate you making
the time crazy schedules and stuff but
at this point the floor is completely
yours because you're our guest so it's
now your time to
shamelessly plug any and everything you
want like literally floor tell them
where to find them what your code is
what's on your shirt what's your guitar
of choice like
everything that the floor is yours man
okay
i play esp guitars because i'm obsessed
with james from metallica
um and i do drink obviously g-fuel promo
code mesa army for 30
off this weekend no i um
i post content and i stream on youtube
gaming
uh just look up mesa shawn twitter is at
mesashawn
on instagram that's mesa underscore sean
and
i finally check out my finally check out
finally and hold on i finally started a
tick tock account
i know he fell down the whole no
well because a lot of cause my friend
who played war
who plays warzone he's constantly having
tick tock um
clips that you know that he puts up i
still i'm i'm a boomer i guess because i
don't know how to use it just yet you
know
like is this thing on you know but um so
yeah so mesa underscore sean on
instagram and twitter and actually
sometimes i'll do giveaways for like g
fuel starter packs or um any you know
my mesa sean scuff controller which i
don't know when the next gens are coming
out everyone keeps asking me
i don't even know and then astro
headsets i'm sponsored by them too
all promo code mace army big shout out
to all the channel members who help
support my channel
every week um and come to the live
streams and i see a lot of them in chat
right now so hi guys
and um that's pretty much it but yeah
guys just thanks again for having me on
guys it's a lot of fun
and let's definitely do this again for
sure i'm sure
man dude legend the legendary basic show
i'm glad we finally was able to make it
happen you guys are legends man
thank you yeah thank you
yeah no don't even say that no no we're
all we all do what we do man
you know how to give him his roses but
he don't like to get him he goes
but at the end of the day is just like
you know one thing i respect about your
content as a person who
started destiny and destiny let's be
real as a new person it could be
intimidating you know
and what i like is i feel like the
person who is the regular dude who's
just trying to get into the game
you know you you provide a forum where
they're comfortable
you know what i'm saying and people can
say okay you know what all right there's
that and what i remember is you
your gunsmith videos of academy i used
to watch those things like
tis arms day i know yeah
you know what i try to be the average
gamer okay you
you're gonna come to my streams you're
not gonna see you know like i said yolo
swag
mlg pve pro stuff okay
okay why do you think i do the expunge
mission every week on stream on my
hunter because i can jump better on the
hunters because you don't want to watch
me fall
a million times you know you will see
bad aim you know what i mean
because i'm trying to get used from the
120 field of view of war zone back to
the 105 you know like field of view
but i feel like people hopefully my
audience can relate to me a little more
because
i'm not gonna spit a million statistics
and numbers and
percentages i'm just gonna say this is
good okay
this i don't really care for or the one
thing that
everyone miss or i feel that everyone
misses in like reviews or top fives or
whatever
that they forget this is i don't know
there's this weird strange
thing that's in all things in the game
they always leave it out it's called fun
okay they're like everything's got to be
the best dps
max range maximum but is it
fun like i was about to drop an f-bomb
right there
it's an effing fun if it's not fun i'm
not going to use it you know
vex me the class is it amazing no when i
run my uh charge with light build and
um quick charge or whatever is it fun
yes does it get the job done yes do i
enjoy using it yes do i flex a little
bit at the tower with it on my back
yes you know what i mean but um same
with outbreak perfected you know
i'm a meme at this point you know if g
fuel says you know after two years i
could probably get my own flavor after
one year i'll get my own
shaker right the channel members you
guys are going to come up with the
flavor
they've already i think kind of coined
mesa berry perfected because
okay oh no every year oh that's the one
you got to do it you got it
with raspberry and it'll be perfected
and if i can i don't know if it's
copyright
i have to clear it with bungee maybe i'd
like to have little nanites on the
on the actual thing and stuff or little
things that maybe look like nanites out
of
a little fun factoid the actual rat king
has an
almost rolex symbol on it um
on the side of it because one particular
developer i don't want to out him or
anything he's a huge rolex fan okay
and then like you know these summit
jewels these destiny summit jewels
continue
so he and i have watched or you know i
used to have watch talk stuff like that
so
i spotted i was like dude did you put a
role like someone like that he's like
well we had
not none he's like no not really he's
like it's changed slightly because
of copyright yeah yeah somebody else
said
and they're like banana on something oh
god yeah
i used to worship that thing i tried to
get one in every flavor before
remember when you could change the
elements of the things right before i've
got it's been so long been playing this
game yeah bro yeah i love that thing
yeah
so that's why for me like the trustee is
like my new banananan but it's full of i
like to trust
i sometimes like to trust you more than
fishing a confluence i don't know
but um well because it's full auto it's
just pointless
in the 200 to 200. i use a full auto
rewind rounds
vision of confluence i know people like
well that you're wasting a perk
in the full auto but i i just like to
hold down the trigger you've always been
full auto you again
always again again it's fun
am i are you using the optimal roll no
but it's fun you know what i mean and
that's you know that's how i play the
game you know
um so and that's enough of my babbling
at the end
but as you can tell i'm gonna delete it
i'm in babble mode stream
you guys know what time it is i'm in
baba mode right now guys so
leave me a hashtag made it to the end if
you didn't make it to the end yeah it is
what about you dog what do you got
coming up uh i know we gotta wait a
little while on one thing that i know
about but for now what else you got
coming that you can talk about because i
can tell you you guys are gonna want to
find him sunday
yeah yeah sunday's gonna be fun man
again if i get salute to basically
coming through a lot of fun
um yeah man this sunday check us out
online podcast every sunday 1 p.m
eastern
big one for us man we got the legends of
343. we're gonna have um
let's talk about some halo infinite
multiplayer we have one of developers
from the game that designed the uh
multiplayer specifically
so come check us out sunday 1 p.m
eastern every sunday's the lord's day
so if you're into halo infinite or
you're just excited you've never played
halo like
mesa in a while and you want to see
what's going on
tune in sunday man we'll have my boy
patrick wren again he'll be in
he'll be in the building again one of
the main main designers on the the new
multiplayer yes also the trailer
everyone's getting hyped but hardcore
halo fans are getting hyped so it'll be
fun to check that out and um yeah man
you got that going and of course for
your website needs please go to lords of
gaming.net
really appreciate that and um also
i know it's a supplement war going on
here that i'm not a part of but i just
support my man e
you know we got my little shaker for his
advanced gg what are you what are you
what are you doing what's the flavor
tonight sir what do you got the uh the
birthday cake today it was very good sir
very good i got it i'm waiting on him i
gotta get some almond milk with that
to get that going on but also salut g
phil i'll see you feeling the building
mace is absolutely
i'm all about the fitness and the
supplements to help us
you know try to get to the gym and get
that little energy up so it's really
cool with that
and of course everybody in here there's
a lot of fun appreciate you know the
last word with my boy partis
you know what i'm saying and every every
week trying to have some fun with this
destiny
and uh yeah e what's going on with you
brother what's poppin man
yeah uh just finished up mass effect 1
so kind of seeing what comes next if we
go straight into two i'm not sure if i
want to kind of you know palette cleanse
a little bit but we will see
of course you guys know tuesdays are
destiny days variety on stream it's
about
a weird name you can find it easily ever
e-b-o-n-t-i-s ivantis
cheetah if you find me twitch twitter
youtube most of those are where i'm at
um of course friday's the last word with
amazing guests so again
yeah ratchet and clank man that is
waiting i got a monitor coming
for hopefully like 4k hdr so i can
actually
prank some of those settings so i got a
couple games waiting so when that thing
shows up
things are going to look a little
prettier uh but yeah again want to thank
you mesa for joining us
um oh thank you guys i mean literally
thanks is all on this end sir
five five years in the making for
meeting you guys at listening to
guardian radio
and then you taking over helping and us
listening to us making a podcast then
just
we had mark on what five six episodes
ago as well so got to catch up with him
so
it's been awesome yeah
if we could ever get kdub on i don't
even know if he's that around it anymore
we've got a lot of you guys on he's busy
he's busy with his business and work and
all that sort of stuff you know
so yeah we we are we are
we appreciate the garden radio crew and
we finally got to got another piece of
the trifecta on here so it's been it's
been awesome
awesome thanks guys uh but for all of
you guys in chat all of the mesa army
thank you
guys as well it's been an awesome show
you guys have been blowing up chat
having a lot of fun a lot of generosity
tonight gift and subs and everything so
all the follows and love tonight you
guys have been awesome as for the end of
stream i always like to go raid another
channel so we actually could go raid uh
sarah it's a very small hat she's
actually going to be a guest here in a
few weeks
so go send some love her direction she's
streaming right now she's a pvp
i don't want to fight her in pvp let's
just say that so she'd wipe the floor
with me so go
send her some names mcgillicuddy yeah
pvp is not my forte against somebody at
that level so
go send it over to her thank you guys
very much but for this episode
june 25th thank you guys very much mesa
amazing guest
we have wrapped this episode for this
episode it has been
the last word